Throughout her life, Her Majesty the Queen, my beloved mother...
...was an inspiration and example to me and to all my family,...
...and we owe her the most heartfelt debt...
...any family could owe to their mother...
...for her love, affection, guidance, understanding and example.
Queen Elizabeth was a life well lived,....
...a promise with destiny kept, and she is mourned most deeply in her passing.
That promise of lifelong service...
...I renew to you all today,...
...freedoms and responsibilities of our unique history...
...and our system of parliamentary government.
As the Queen herself did with such unswerving devotion,...
...I, too, now solemnly pledge myself...
...throughout the remaining time God grants me...
...to uphold the constitutional principles at the heart of our nation.
In a little over a week's time,...
...we will come together as a nation, as a Commonwealth,...
...and indeed a global community,...
...to lay my beloved mother to rest.
In our sorrow, let us remember and draw strength from the light of her example.
On behalf of all my family,...
...I can only offer the most sincere and heartfelt thanks...
...for your condolences and support.
They mean more to me than I can ever possibly express.